I'm sitting next to Kelly Clarkson oh my
god I've seen Jay hood all the way let
go I probably make you uncomfortable how
many times I tell you how hot you are
foot I always thought your beautiful
little lady point you for doing the
promo shoot and I was like oh god I
gotta stand next to that you're so
beautiful I just want to be your best
friend I just want to hang out I wanted
to say she talked to you I think we
should I was like I was a with Jennifer
when her chest I'm Kelly's house off I
mean I'm not gonna live
I would pick Jennifer are you I want to
sing with you I want to I think you've
one of the greatest voices ever I think
you have one of the great like you're
bad down to earth you have very down to
earth
you know that I'm glad I don't know how
people aren't down to earth I don't know
what happens when you start flying on
the earth you know what I think it is I
think it's because we started out
regular people I don't know any other
way to be and I've noticed to working
this season with you I like how you pick
your team it is the voice but it's like
a voice that speaks to you so maybe
isn't the one that everybody thinks
thank you
it is not always the most powerful voice
that connects or moves someone that is
true the greatest fear of all time is
somebody that connects with people I
love that you like singers but it makes
it harder for us to compete because it's
like we're similar but we're different
yeah the blinds was hard what it'll be
like yeah like soulful sing it too oh
wait you get that off and I want to be
on your team that happened to me too me
too
I love her I want to be on Jennifer's
team it doesn't happen with the boys but
it happens with you up want to be on the
boys see ya know
[Music]